muga with Miley big smiles with Elton
Anderson and Andy yep
celebs loved us I want to go to the top
of a mountain and just scream and so do
we
here are three reasons why the newly out
Olympian is our crush to watch in 2016
number one all those shirtless selfies
I've kind of tried to steer away from it
but III think that it's just that I had
so much kind of layered on top of me
just like hide my sexuality that it was
kind of nice just like be able to do
something that felt more me from selfies
to so cheap reason number two puppies
remember all those stray dogs at the
Olympics well Ken where they rescued for
the straight situation area is really
sad so I think that people have kind of
just been enamoured by it the dogs are
doing really well they're doing great
they've adjusted well and they're very
loved and cared for it so cute and now
number three he's an athlete turned role
model Caitlyn Jenner story after coming
out in ESPN magazine and on Twitter the
freestyle ski champ is all over social
media promoting tolerance these are the
8 things you should never say to your
gay friends you don't really seem gay
the last few years definitely struggled
a lot more and really kind of felt like
I needed to put it out there feels so
good to have the weight lifted off my
shoulder I just wanted to say thank you
and let's just go for a run okay